Neels runs a media company in the
densely populated hunts dot region
fiber-to-the-home now allows him to
spend more time with his family at the
countryside home more than an hour from
his place of work what I do from home
especially work on the computer and my
work in detects I spend there my time to
to talk with people and especially
social activities and to get some
inspiration from colleagues I can spend
more time with my family and I have two
grown-up children
well they need also some time with me so
I can have them so it's better to work
from home and I can see them earlier and
well in the rest of the time I go to use
Nexus but they know that I can do more
in the same time because otherwise I
spend more time in the car and well that
is that's not not very convenient and
we're working from home especially in in
prime time it's it's easier to do
daughter milu goes to university in
another town fiber helps her keep up
when she's visiting her family we have
some virtual private network so we can
log in on the internet and we have
blackboards it's an online learning
center we have to make a test every
Sunday only blackboards the high speed
connection allows the entire family to
use bandwidth intensive applications at
the same time the test is in a limited
time as the rest of the family is a on
the internet with my brother he came for
love and I don't have any problem I can
work for his team
oh yeah you can chat in game with other
people around the world with no latency
and you can just check Facebook or
something voyage gaming or
live-streaming
when it's not studying some loot earn
some extra money working from home I
upload a little movies funny movies to a
site where people can watch and because
of the high upload speed it's very fast
so I can do my job to the local fibre
network even allowed one of me lose
classmates to follow classes from home
during a prolonged illness yeah a friend
and she was here for a long time so we
had a computer at the back of the class
and she can't follow lessons through the
can and yeah it takes some time off when
she needed and take her owner speeds the
provider brings high-definition TV
services to the living room after work
mother Marlon watch is a show broadcast
earlier that day I like to watch several
programs and yes of course I can I can
watch chef and computer Niels can
collaborate on projects and access large
media files from home any time fiber
enables a flexible work schedule and
even helps them stay fit and you go
running it's cost more than three times
a week to have a training and now it's
easier to do it in the morning and I use
them an application on my phone and I
can also lock my good well and after
that running I go further with my work
it's easy to combine fiber-to-the-home
changing how we work and live